so it's it's now my pleasure to bring
back to the stage president Bollinger
who really is as I said earlier he's
really responsible for renaissance in
relationships with alumni when I became
a trustee a few years ago I was watching
what he was doing I was learning a lot
really getting a crash course in
Columbia and one thing he said to me I
said well you know what are the things
that are important to you and he said
you know having the big idea is really
what makes a university great and
manhattanville is a big idea there are
other big ideas and I just sort of put
things in that framework when I look at
our global centers when I look at other
things that are going on so president
Bollinger is somebody that I'm very
proud to work with in addition to making
the university a very exciting place and
reaching out to alumni he also is has a
special place in his heart for
journalism which is my field this past
fall he taught a course a free press for
global society focused on issues that he
addresses in his most recent book
uninhibited robust and wide open a free
press for a new century president
Bollinger
well thank you again Olivia and it's
wonderful to have you on the board of
trustees and doing this we have the last
panel here as a very very significant
topic and that is global media global
press global understanding but because
of the nature of that discussion
inevitably we will take up the press
generally and there are a lot of things
to discuss there so we have three they
said panelists and let me introduce them
very briefly before we start Julius
Genachowski is chairman of the Federal
Communications Commission of course as
you know an agency he previously served
in several capacities including chief
counsel to then chairman read hunt under
his leadership the FCC has worked to
expand broadband capacity across the
United States and has tackled the
controversial issue of net neutrality
after law school he served as a law
clerk for Supreme Court justices William
Brennan and David Souter and he is a
graduate of Columbia College Claire
Shipman is a senior national
correspondent for good morning america
before joining ABC News she was the
White House correspondent for NBC News
and spent a decade with CNN over her
career she has covered a remarkable
series of historic events including
Tiananmen Square the aborted Soviet coup
and subsequent collapse of the Soviet
Union Boris Yeltsin's assault on the
Russian parliament building and the
Oklahoma City bombing where recently
claire has reported from iraq and on the
2008 presidential election her
exceptional journalism has been honored
with multiple awards she is a graduate
of Columbia College and the School of
International Affairs public policy and
international affairs Nicholas lemon was
the Dean of
our graduate school journalism and the
Henry are loose professor of journalism
when he came to Columbia in 2003 and we
were incredibly lucky to entice him to
become Dean he was serving as the New
Yorkers Washington correspondent and
experience that no doubt will enter into
his discussion today he's been
responsible for leading the journalism
school during a transformative period
for the profession and has responded
with an incredible array of innovations
in school he has published five books
and continues to write for The New
Yorker so that's the group let's begin
I'm sit down just second but I use this
mic with claire and i think i think
since we're beginning our focus is sort
of global media and understanding of
international issues and you've had this
deep long experience with major press
organizations and especially in the
broadcast area if you could talk about
how you see those institutions now and
their capacity or incapacity to cover
international global events that would
be a great start for us absolutely at
least you didn't say i've just bounced
around from place to place it sounded
much more elegant yeah but a one more
network and i probably will have covered
them all it is it's remarkable when i
think back to the state of affairs when
I was in Moscow for CNN and the way you
know I things were both at CNN and what
I observed very closely from the way the
network's operated and watching for
example what is the reality today the
investment in covering foreign stories
has plummeted this is probably not a
surprise to many of you who read papers
or watch television and that's been a
long-standing slide but when I think
about the time I spent for example in
1991 in Moscow and and the kind of
coverage we and the network's really
provided covering the aborted coup and
and Gorbachev and and the transition the
end of the Soviet Union I think we
probably had one or two store
he's on the air every day for six months
and we we also had the ability because
we had a full bureau there with people
who had I was a lot younger than but I
did have my Harriman Institute
certificate and my international affairs
degree and I had some experience in
Russia but we had a full team of really
experienced reporters and producers on
the ground that I think really gave our
coverage distinction but the network's
had the same thing I mean the networks
were really heavily invested as well and
when I look at what's happened for
example now in the way the the spring
the Arab Spring is unfolding and
everything going on in the Middle East
the coverage is riveting it's very
exciting and it's especially exciting to
watch what is happening with with
Facebook and Twitter and driving that
revolution as we were talking about the
networks have given it a lot of coverage
when it's hot but it also feeds very
quickly I think you'll see from from the
headlines and it just doesn't stay if
you wanted to find out what's going on
in Egypt I don't think there's been a
lot of continuity in terms of that story
on the network news lately so I think
we've seen you know across the board
we've seen a slashing of you know
probably fifty percent at ABC a lot like
everywhere else over the years I mean
it's a it's a huge cut and it's it's
felt in terms of you know the ability to
go out and be in places for long periods
of time whether it's with a bureau
whether it's you know extended stays in
a country but to bring that depth of
knowledge to bear that that helps to
compel things to get on the air but we
also feel it we do feel it in domestic
news as well and we feel it in our
ability to do domestic investigative
journalism there's just less of an
appetite when for me at Good Morning
America earning America if I'm proposing
something that would take two or three
weeks to work on mombasa below me to
convince anybody of now you know a
couple of days of spending on shooting
is just about all anybody
stomach so I think it's you know we we
were at a big party in washington
recently in a very prominent politician
said he was looking at what happened in
Egypt and he said you know this is so
exciting Mark Zuckerberg is is like the
Thomas Jefferson of our generation or
the James Madison and I and we thought
about that and what's you know what
facebook has done is enormously exciting
and in a lot of ways I see a lot of
parallels to the role CNN played in the
coverage of the Soviet coo you know CNN
was just being broadcast in Moscow at
that point and that access was
incredibly important for informing the
Russian people what was going on and it
was by mistake by the way they somebody
was supposed to flip that switch off and
they forgot and it was broadcast all
across Moscow and everybody knew what
was happening and what to do and it's
it's similar but i guess i will leave
you with that question about whether you
know is is Mark Zuckerberg that the
Thomas Jefferson of our generation or is
there you know is he the creator of an
incredible tool so here's the problem
I'm supposed to be the moderate I'm
sorry but I'm ever but i have but i have
intense feelings about that question and
i can't resist it and I want to be
provocative so we have an interesting
panel I would say it's incomprehensible
to think of Mark Zuckerberg as Thomas M
that that one so I mean I'm putting this
out as a hypothesis you know say so one
person's distinction is based on content
on ideas and the other person's is on
inventing you know it's a very
significant achievement to invent
something that is a communications
technology but I wouldn't say that there
they may be comparable in terms of the
effects on the world but i wouldn't put
them in the same category and i and and
i want to turn this over to julius
because i think he disagrees with no no
no III wouldn't disagree with that but i
think the more apt analogy might be with
gutenberg right because the
a platform of the internet as a way for
people to receive information to share
information and now on top of that the
social networking activities tools like
Facebook like Twitter are having just a
profound effect on the world every level
from what we've seen over the last few
weeks in North Africa in the Middle East
wouldn't have happened without new
communications technologies to the
effect on journalism in the United
States query whether the rise of the
Internet the challenge to traditional
business models as part of the reason to
Claire seeing what she's seeing
certainly on a local level we're seeing
effects like that but just to stay with
the Egypt in North Africa for a minute a
lot of people asked when the internet
was shut down in Egypt and mobile
service was shut down wow how could they
do that what does this mean very
important questions there is very
difficult issues but less frequently
asked was the question of how did it
happen that Egypt had an Internet and a
mobile service that was worth shutting
down and that's its own really
interesting topic underneath it is a
revolution that's happened around the
world and the rollout of communications
infrastructure like mobile and to a
certain extent like the internet that's
good and it's raising a whole series of
profound new issues around more visible
now after the last few weeks around
whether a free and open Internet is
sustainable worldwide sustained
globally versus the risks of a
balkanized internet which would be
tragic in my opinion both from free
speech and human rights perspective also
from global prosperity and global
economic perspective so I've thrown out
a few issues but I'm going with
Guttenberg so Julius on and the so
Claire paints a picture of traditional
press organizations institutions as
having cutbacks severely on their
capacity to cover global affairs
international affairs and probably
that's we can take that as a a given of
the discussion right I mean we all know
that every major press institution in
the United States almost all of them
except perhaps the financially oriented
ones right our really pale versions of
what they were ten years ago or
certainly 20 years ago I think I would
ask this question of you to what extent
is that a matter of public policy and
what forms of public policy clearly what
you started talking about is very very
important that is you've been very very
big on universal access to to the
Internet so if you can talk more about
that and what that means for this
reality and anything else that's a
matter of public policy that relates to
this reality what's it so much of public
policy in the media area and up sitting
next to the real expert on this is has
been driven for the last 50 years by
certain scarcities whether it was a
limited amount of spectrum allocated for
broadcasting that gave us only a certain
number
over the year channels in particular
communities or whether it was economics
that created in effect one newspaper no
more than one in in almost every market
in the country and so that those
elements of scarcity led to certain
kinds of public policies that were
adopted adopted over the years that
either made sense or didn't but but you
know the the they formed that discussion
that debate we're in a completely
different world now or at least we're in
a transition to a completely different
world presuming that the internet stays
free and open and that it becomes
something that everyone has access to
and so the questions for Public Policy
are very different not in a world of
scarcity what to do what to do with
respect to content that's either not
there or that is there but is
problematic but rather issues that stem
from the nature of the internet one of
the big issues I think is how do we keep
preserve the character of the internet
that's been open that's been
characterized by freedom how do we
preserve that in the United States how
do we make that our chief export or one
of our chief exports to the rest of the
world that presents a lot of public
policy issues how do we make sure that
everyone has access to broadband those
create public policy issues and then
there's a third category and I don't
expend doing work on this which is this
question of okay in this new world will
there or won't there be categories of
content that's important for citizenship
important for participation in our
democracy important for participation in
our economy that
may not be provided you know what are
those categories if they're important
and they're not going to be provided by
the internet big f what if anything
should public policy do about that so I
think we're all at the relatively early
stages in identifying the questions
starting to do the work to analyze it
we're doing some work at the FCC makes
been doing a lot of work at the j-school
but they're different questions than the
public policy questions that have been
asked for the last 50 years Nick what do
you think about all this well I think
about it a lot i want to say first you
know in his famous manifesto for
founding National Review William F
Buckley wrote my aim is to stand athwart
history yelling stop there is a
tremendous temptation to do that in
journalism these days but it's
impossible and it's not a useful role
for Columbia Journalism school or our
profession generally so what we're
trying to do what I'm trying to do is a
journalist and citizen and Dean and what
our school i believe is trying to do is
change as rapidly as the world is
changing and try to participate in
getting our graduates ready for the new
world which I think we're doing quite
well right now for their the
beneficiaries many of them of some of
the trends that you were talking about
Clare and to try to shape the
conversation going forward with research
and many other means to this is a moment
i know that julius knows very well Paul
star who is a prophetic alum be a
college graduate first and foremost but
also an eminent sociologist at Princeton
who wrote a
a book called the creation of the media
I spoke at a conference on the book and
I discovered that the key concept in the
book is one that no one can pronounce
which is constitutive moments I think
I've cut that right fit if at home
there's some people call it constitutive
moments anyway the idea is every once in
a while everything gets thrown up in the
air and then it comes down in a
different place and that may be true in
all realms of existence certainly true
in the media world and we are in one of
those moments so the journalism school
and even the president of the university
are in a position to have a real
significant and meaningful influence on
where things will land now that they're
all up in the air and it's incumbent on
us to be extremely vigorous participants
in this discussion as Lee has done
better than any of us by publishing the
book he published last year let me stop
there and if you want to ask a follow-up
at one of these subcategories only
answer that so let's um let's go to
public funding I me use it one of the
ways to to deal with this let's let's
assume we clearly want universal
broadband access I mean that that's a
good how you get there and I'm sure it's
really hard and complicated they clearly
want that as a society we want all of us
here going through a place like Columbia
I mean you want the world to have what
it is that a student at Columbia gets
everybody should have that in an ideal
world do everybody should be have the
access to information and and it should
be provided by people who are experts
and people who are not experts but
they've got views we should have access
to all of that a lot of times we decide
as a society that we're not going to get
enough of something if we just leave it
to the market and the last 25 years has
seen that the dominance of a kind of
market free market view in the society
for organizing almost everything and yet
we know that universities could not
exist if they were as we know them and
love them if we put them in the free
market we know that science basic
science in the country would not be done
unless we had the NIH and the NSF
funding this at very massive scale we
know we wouldn't have Yosemite and
Yellowstone and so on if there were not
a public intervention to do this so why
what are the prospects and what would
you think about a significant amount of
public funding in the country well going
into this area of journalism Nick a
couple of things first of all going back
to something Julius said it it may be
that there is and it's not proven but it
may be that there is an absolute
trade-off between what is socially
desirable on the receipt end of media
and what is socially desirable in the
production end of media that is the not
not always great about the vanished age
of bigger news for big newsrooms bye-bye
big established professional news
organizations I don't think those days
are coming back anyway but you know they
were monopolistic or oligopolistic and
they had many flaws but the fact that no
one could compete with them because it
was a very very high barrier to entry
business and the fact that they didn't
operate in the analog of what we now
call net neutrality meant that as he
would say they could charge very
high rents for what they did and that
with some shaming and blaming from
Columbia Journalism school pushing the
process forward created these very big
news rooms so I love your vision your
it's a very it's a inspiring Democratic
vision in terms of the ability to get
journalism and the ability for anybody
to just go home right now and be a jerk
the most famous single line ever written
by a graduate of Columbia Journalism
school i think is freedom of the press
belongs only to those who own one AJ
Liebling class of 25 well that's not
true anymore and it's a wonderful thing
for the world but if you get all that
which we should get and is wonderful the
other side of it is that the production
doesn't get financed in many areas so I
think what we need to do now is engage
the period of very careful learning and
debate on several topics we need to be
very careful about figuring out and
giving it a few years what the market
actually will support many many many
people are experimenting with this we're
about to publish at the school a big
report on what we know as about this as
of now so it could be that ways of
supporting production of news that are
unfamiliar to us today we'll be there in
five years as Lee said the situation is
pretty optimistic for business and
financial news being supported by the
market for example I believe based on
what I know that there are other kinds
of news that aren't likely to be
supported by the market to the extent
that I believe they would be good for
people all over the world so then the
question is how do they get supported
the nonprofit sector is in that space
more than it ever has been but maybe not
enough and you know foundations don't
like to support things on an ongoing
basis forever what strikes me is how
many of my journalistic colleagues
regard public funding as just a
non-starter because they identify it
with at the very best trouble and at the
worst you know Pravda and so I would
like and I know you would likely to
enrich that discussion a bit get people
to lower their barriers
and say you know the distinction made at
one of our events that you were at by
rei of open society institute that was
very good is there's a difference
between public media and government
meteor state media and what we're
talking about is public nuts state so
taking people's doubts as a challenge
and these are real world political get
it done doubts and is it a good thing
doubts it falls on us to try to figure
out ways this could be done that there
would be affordable not self negating
and and and not subject to censorship
the numbers are the least of it at
various cost estimates I've seen you
know in the scheme of things it's pretty
cheap too very have a really big
increase in the number of reporters in
the United States one quick final thing
we need to also be disciplined about you
know there's a tendency is somewhat lazy
tenants and the part of journalists say
any person who happens to be on the
payroll of a news organization is
providing vital and unique information
about the performance of public entities
so we get called on that kind of
statement align we're right to be when
we should part of what's good about this
discussion is it makes us journalists be
much more careful and precise about
exactly what in journalism has value and
and and and that would allow this
discussion to go forward so let's
continue this because I would I've
advocated as Nick knows and for an
American World Service something that
would take the system we've had a voice
of america radio for europe and either
shut that down and say it was right for
the quarter century or half century that
it existed but but now it's no longer it
will always be the voice of american
government and it has serious journalism
but it's not only that and really fund
NPR PBS and give them a more global kind
of reach this is what other countries
are doing i think the world is missing
the kind of professional journal
that that we could provide one of the
arguments is that that will inevitably
lead to government intervention into
journalism of course we've got the
example already of NPR and PBS and and
that for good or bad but Julius what
would you say about the what does the
history of the FCC which has had an
enormous oversight and involvement with
the press a branch of the press since
nineteen twenty seven does that history
give us confidence that we could have a
significant publicly funded media in the
United States and and not have the
serious risk of government intervention
let me start with a point about history
that predates the FCC you know we've
we've had over the years and Paul start
talks about this in his book a number of
different attempts to get at this
problem typically related to the
technologies of the day and the market
circumstances of the day and so at the
time of the revolution the distribution
of newspapers and pamphlets through the
mail system was discounted right it was
an example of public funding that
actually according to pole stars
conclusion is was one of the things that
accelerated the development of a
journalism business in the United States
faster than Europe right um I think we
need to tackle or let me put it this way
i think that the that it's most likely
that the solutions to the new problems
we're facing you know will be new ones
and not old ones now in one hand some of
the the core needs are the same you know
we need people like Claire Shipman in
journalism with her job structured as it
has been at times throughout her career
where she has time to really dig into
something and report and study and take
advantage of her background and provide
all those incredible benefits to the
public we also need
today's clear shipments in college to
decide that they're going to go into
journalism and let me just reserve a
question for later because I'm actually
curious about that Claire and I at
Columbia both worked on the spectator I
wonder what students are doing now today
let me come back to that for a minute
but in terms of you know the kinds of
solutions that new technologies might
allow that affect business models in a
healthy way that raise fewer of the
entanglements and First Amendment
concerns that come up with some of the
older ways of either regulation or
public funding technology allows for a
dramatic revolution in the transparency
of government and the availability of
government data and so everything from
just making it really easy for a
reporter you know at home to just watch
a city council meeting without actually
having to go there get data about what
the City Council is doing with different
government agencies are doing in
searchable machine-readable formats
doing a kind of analysis that previously
you know really hard to do so I'm
raising the question of if you had a
limited amount of government money to
spend how much of it would you spend on
accelerating new technologies to provide
all sorts of better information faster
to people versus taking that same amount
of money and funding a news organization
in a traditional way if we had to make
choices which would we do those are the
kinds of things we should be discussing
I'm interested in these other ideas one
because i think it lowers the costs of
news gathering at some level i also
think it creates new opportunities for
news entities to monetize information
and can help with business models in
ways that are not obvious if you're only
looking in the rearview mirror but start
to become a little clearer if you look
at what commercial companies are doing
now with data and how they're monetizing
that so
well let me stop there but I think I
don't but I very rich area but i think
the the theme of this is a period of
enormous uncertainty enormous change and
so on and it's not a moment therefore to
intervene with ideas that seem to come
out of the history of our experience but
to wait and see a bit as to what's
possible that's the kind of clear what
do you think where is your well I've
been striking yeah even though I
appreciate that you know we really
should view this as an attempt for me to
stay employed that's what all the fuss
about Thank You Julius and that it is
some days really you know what I look
around and think about the changes it's
it's it's it's hard as a journalist
having been in the field that long but
when you when I remain an optimist about
what's happening really because there
are examples of in my home state ohio i
saw the other day that you know a group
of and you probably know more about the
snake but a group of the the largest
local papers have banded together and
formed a sort of consortium to try to
share costs and they and they've come up
with it what they think is a formula
that will help each of them individually
be able to devote more money to some
investigative stuff than the other the
general stuff is covered together i just
read a piece about a guy from wired who
is starting with the Atavist a great new
online multimedia venture to try to to
for money you know to sell at two or
three dollars for really in-depth
interesting reported pieces and they
think that that might be a business
model and master just think the ipad and
what the new york times is doing i mean
the people will pay but i think we you
know the big question is just how how do
we how do we pay for this journalism but
i think there are some kernels of hope
and i think it's right that we need to
let things percolate a little bit before
and frankly we were talking about this
earlier i mean i just do not see
covering politics in Washington an
appetite for Eva as minuscule is the
investment by
might be yeah in real dollars
symbolically it would just be I think a
mountain too high right now right I mean
it's only investing we're only talking
about four or five hundred million
dollars in the four trillion dollar
budget so it's really you take that to
Capitol Hill in this environment in it I
got ok I understand it but my role in
life is to come up completely
unrealistic it is that's yeah in a
little bit we'll open it up for some
questions but I must say I am prompted
ask a question that moves away from the
press area and goes into the university
area and what I want to ask you is do
you see universities sort of next in
line to be going through this kind of
transformation that the press has been
in just for the past five years because
they're actually very short period of
time that people in the press have been
now exposed to the sense of
disintegration of the world as as
they've known it and I think all of us
can just think back to eight ten years
when people thought it was impossible
that he will give up the newspaper in
the morning and get impossible that the
network's would be what they are today
do you think universities are in line
and would that be a pity if if they
started sort of disintegrating in the
same way and people said look if you
want to if you want to read and listen
to a great person on Plato's Republic
there's a place on the internet where
you can get it why would you want to pay
fifty thousand dollars a year to
Columbia yeah to do that Nick one of the
good things about being Dean of Columbia
Journalism school is that it puts me in
touch with the rest of higher education
because as you know of Columbia's said
of Ivy League plus peer institutions
we're the only one that gives a
journalism degree so I spend a lot of
quality time with
folks from shippensburg State University
and Pennsylvanian places like that I'm
much more I would be much more worried
if I were them than if I were Columbia
what you're really talking about I mean
there are these forms of aggregated
human activity where each single piece
doesn't have to stand on its own
economically and department stores were
one and you know i don't i don't know if
you can still go to woodward and lo
threw up in downtown Washington maybe
not but and newspapers were an example
of an elaborate cross subsidy scheme I
think Columbia Columbia's got it seems
like the safest of institutions but
lower down in education you are seeing a
lot of conversation along the lines of
let's take each unit of the University
and make it justify itself and we really
see it and where I really value Columbia
particularly the college is a relentless
focus and insistence on skills as being
what college is there to teach Bill
Gates actually gave a speech the other
day I don't if people saw we said no one
should take humanities courses in
college they should only take skills
courses state legislators are all over
the public sector of higher ed parents
are all over other colleges that you
could not recreate Columbia University
so in that sense it's not as susceptible
to competition from new players and and
the imputed and I think real credential
value of the degree the in-person
affects the network effects all those
things are so high that I don't think
there's going to be a lot of parents say
I'm not paying for any philosophy
department but that is happening already
in less fortunate parts of high red
Julis what do you see I agree with Nick
that a place like Columbia deservedly
occupies a place in our society that
shouldn't change dramatically and and
and I don't think it will but also
accepting the various things that Nick
said about improvements I guess I'd make
a couple of points in thinking about
education and new technologies one is
the opportunity for universities to lead
on identifying the ways to harness
technology to serve traditional goals
and values you know reflected in our
core curriculum etc well I hope Columbia
is the place that figures it figures
that out you know and then the as an
access point for broader communities you
know however well I succeed and others
do at universal broadband access we're
not going to get 100 gigabits to
everyone's home and there's going to be
a compelling need for centers of
collaboration that have you know super
high connections and that are
collaborating non-stop with research and
thinking into these in the US and around
the world and I sure hope Colombia is
leading in that a couple of other points
just moving away from Colombia for a
minute very briefly one is I do think
the opportunities for communications
technology to transform other parts of
education for the better very exciting
and so to transform community colleges
to help that audience really become
prepared for finding jobs in a new
economy very exciting opportunities and
to transform k to 12 education you know
here's a simple vision we should be the
first country in the world to switch
from paper text books for kids to
digital textbooks you know
the last country in a world to require
kids everywhere to carry around
backpacks with 50 pounds of out-of-date
books in the first country to think
about tablets and textbooks as force
multipliers for teachers that you know
kind of inspire and engage kids and that
equalize opportunity around the country
so i'm i'm i think is a wonderful vision
around around that that i hope we pursue
as a country and I think that
institutions like Columbia can help
figure it out and raise the value of
education at other institutions Claire
just on the same theme are there lessons
can you see any lessons for universities
and columbia in particular in what you
feel the press has gone through in the
past decade that's a great question well
i mean first of all don't rely heavily
on advertising yeah i don't think you so
i think we know make the endowments in
good shape and we rely on Alumni giving
that's what yes exactly but I do think
that you know there is a sense of
wanting to hang on to the good old days
and do things the same way and if only
we had four more crews you know we could
really be doing X and I think that you
know that the networks and and you know
everybody's been struggling with this
but I think trying to look to the future
as Julius was talking about for
solutions as opposed to looking for ways
to to fix it from the past is is key and
I think it's taken the network's a long
time to get that and I don't we're still
we're still struggling with that yeah I
mean there are kids are just it's
exactly what you said I mean my son is
all he wants to do now is read books on
my iPad yeah and initially I thought
this is wrong wrong wrong and you know
it's a just part of their their blood
and I think finding the ways to to
embrace that and use the
managers I think that Columbia would
benefit from that terrific well let's
open it up for for some questions so
people can go to the mics of doing
online degree yes over here thank you my
name is Charles Schwab Columbia class of
65 law school 68 Claire Shipman
mentioned the Arab Spring and we've seen
recently journalists being abducted
attacked even worse and it's not a
recent phenomenon and even in countries
where where there's a conflict and
journalists are allowed in they may be
limited as to where they go watch where
they go is there a danger or journalists
to become influence than how they report
become inhibited and what they say just
as a matter of self-protection and how
do you guard against that let's let's
you want to respond I mean I one thing
we can do because we've got a number of
people one asked questions take three at
a time and and then respond to them is
one do that we then get through more
giving people more upper to the Columbia
is doing multiple choice now yeah my
name is psycho Thomas and I'll preface
my statements I do work for the state
department and I know that I was with a
number of colleagues when we got word
that I've Afghanistan 12 members of the
UN staff there were killed after Friday
prayers on Afghanistan I know a couple
of my colleagues looked at me and stated
that they wished that when the pastor in
florida first started making statements
about going to him deciding to burn the
quran and all the attention was given to
him we said we wish that the in general
media outlets wouldn't have paid so much
attention to him and we thought that it
gave more attention and prominence to
him than what he really even needed so
my question is what responsibility do
journalists have to ensure that the
stories that they're going after are not
just about how many publications can
they sell what's the hot
news or what's the hot topic but
actually what's a story that's going to
give value and not lead to what we've
seen across the Arab world okay thank
you and one more question then we'll
have some answers Hank Wallace 70 law
can you educate the public to under to
appreciate the basic structures of
journalism for example it's common for
somebody to say Oh Julius Genachowski in
an editorial in yesterday's Washington
Post and maybe in an op-ed a crucial
distinction and somebody will when asked
well what do you think of the reportage
of the various news organizations will
say well I like O'Reilly or I like Matt
oh but they're commentators no
distinction from that between that and
the reportage but also educating the
news organizations themselves where a
sense of a basic thing like priority of
news being subverted we're here in news
networks sometimes saying we'll have
breaking news after this message okay so
we've got I think some interesting
questions about you know are we losing
our concept of news what do you think
about the responsibilities of
journalists who anticipate to figure out
what is important what's not important
but they anticipate really bad
consequences and to have that affect
your your judgment and also our
journalists inhibited in their reporting
by the need to try to get access to the
clarity wants to pick any one of those
well the first question you know there
are a lot of analogies to the time we
spent reporting in the Soviet Union and
you know in the early days when I was
there we were still watched and we would
hear if if somebody didn't like our
reports and we were often it told it
will we didn't like that report so we're
not going to okay your visa to travel to
Ukraine next week or and that end
it is different than feeling that you're
in real physical danger based on what
what you do or say but I think there's
just a long-standing tradition of
journalists who go to dangerous places
and cover things in ways that that
really put themself and I think that you
know journalists are not really a bunch
to be inhibited I mean especially when
you see the foreign journalists who go
into stories I mean they're there
because they want to tell the story and
I really I mean Nick can talk about that
too but I usually see people taking much
greater personal risks than maybe even
they should in order to to get the story
out but but clearly that can sometimes
be of a problem Nick I guess I should
speak to one of the other questions
because that was a wonderful answer to
that question on making it educating
journalists about these categorical
distinction journalism of course we do
that but i want to put kind of an
asterisk on it two things that i'm proud
of that we do at the school in the last
few years one is we require all students
to take a history of Journalism course
and the second is we develop sort of a
business school style case method
teaching with written cases about
ethical issues and journalism I really
want our students and everybody to think
about these distinctions but remember
that they change the categories change
all the time in the days before cable
television and the Fairness Doctrine
there was no Fox News to put in a
category I'm old enough to remember when
op-ed pages didn't exist so you didn't
have to explain the difference between
and they may not exist in 20 years so I
think it's important to for people to
think through the underlying functions
and how they fit together and how
they've changed over time knowing that
they will change again rather than to
say here is the firm
please memorize it should say there's
also a kind of movement in journalism
education to offer courses outside of
journalism schools called media literacy
to undergraduate so they'll understand
Allah stuff and I'll also confess that I
don't if Michelle moody Adams is still
here but I haven't even dared to ask her
if this could be part of the Columbia
core curriculum there I've been urged to
because I just I can't think of how she
could possibly say yes to adding another
course to the core curriculum the final
thing just quickly on the question from
from over here I think the idea about
selling papers is a little bit it's not
that we don't worry about that and and
you know there is something to be said
as we've discussing for the market
supporting journalism I think I can say
safely no story abroad no matter how
incendiary has ever put up by the
American press to sell papers if it were
a story about britney spears being in
rehab yes it's more it's not that we
publish everything willy nilly even
Julian Assange says that he censored a
lot of the wikileaks stuff if he thought
that it would endanger somebody and
certainly mainstream organizations do
more of that than you would think at the
same time you know we live in a
pluralistic society the Senate behaves
in certain ways because of how it's
designed that are in opposition out of
the house behaves and that's part of how
our system works and it's different from
other judiciary behaves the press always
or is on the side of thinking more
information made public will be good for
the world more open discussion and I
know it just doesn't look that way if
you're inside government and it's a
creative tension that just does and
should play itself out everyday drill
this anything no just a brief thing I
think you know the kind of activities
that Claire the question went to and the
clare describe the heroic activities of
journalists around the world putting
themselves in real
danger and the work that that Nick is
doing at the journalism school it just I
think it it reminds us that cultural
norms and an awareness of the historic
role that that the journalists and
journalism have played in advancing our
democracy how important that is and so
I'm just very happy to hear make about
your focus I think it's important I do
sometimes worry about whether enough is
being done to sustain that teach that to
a new generation given all the new
challenges and and I'm intrigued by the
core curriculum idea because I think
we'd lose a lot as society if we lose
these these important norms and I do
think there's a way in which the
internet threatens them and we should
wrestle with that okay yes three more I
think one of the most interesting and
exciting things would also want most
daunting things I've seen out of it
so-called Arab Spring was this
proliferation of I would almost like
grassroots journalism where you see
people with Twitter accounts and
smartphones or taking pictures and
writing brief updates on the ground not
even journalists just citizens who are
taking pictures with our phones but then
they're also journalists for example you
know al Jazeera who have bloggers on the
ground and then even governments and
militaries I remember a few years back
during the Gaza incursion that the
Israeli military had a blog about
experience and it just seems like
there's proliferation of information
it's really exciting but there's this
trouble this this challenge of compiling
as a reader finding out who to read who
to trust what do you think the American
journalists role is with this sort of
new development you know I know that I'm
sorry that's all right three no jump in
go ahead I was just going to say I
thought that we we um you know when we
when we cover stories and I've watched
the reporters who are covering
stories in the Middle East we will try
to sift through a lot of that now I mean
that's part of the reporting job that
they do is not just reporting what's on
the ground but looking at what's been
posted on YouTube and what's on Twitter
and what are people saying on facebook
and so it's a whole new territory and
you know part of our job we think at
this point is to sift through a lot of
that as well and to to try to call that
information I don't know if that's just
a temporary phase because it I mean it
is really a sort of democratization of
journalism and I think a lot of people
are happy to cut us out as the middleman
but I also think that ultimately there
are a lot of people like you who feel
overwhelmed by it all and that's where i
think you know in addition to to the
idea we had about where is the payment
issue going i think where is the you
know the the information and things
sifting down to maybe a you know a few
sources or a number of sources that
people can count on that are doing that
job for you yes I am my question has to
do with media representation of global
South countries and so there was an
article by guy Uriel Charles on CNN and
he was talk it was called stop calling
quake victims looters and I was talking
about how I had a picture from readers
of a Haitian man after the earthquake in
the street and he had food in his hand
and the caption was Haitian man lewd
looting a market and they had also a
picture from Reuters also of a Caucasian
woman after Hurricane Katrina in the
street doing the same thing but the
caption was a woman finding food at a
local grocery store another thing would
be that um there are dead bodies on TV
shown all that all the time whenever
stories of like genocide and Sudan is
being covered or they cover like victims
of rebel forces in
rwanda when those doors are being
covered they air that type of footage of
the dead bodies but then that would
never be the case if after 911 or the
Virginia Tech shooting like course that
would be very disrespected so it speaks
to the idea that a higher value is
placed on American life so my question
for you is what is your opinion when
patterns like this get brought up and
how do you address them okay thank you
it would take another question added to
these mix of what's happening
technologically what that means for
established news organizations and then
if you introduce the notion of public
support I listened to NPR radio just
about every every day and you have to
then into this mix introduce the notion
of politics because conservatives in
this country have always wanted to cut
public funding for what seems to me as
an ex newspaper man you know right down
the line journalism on on NPR so this
makes me pessimistic that you can have
public funding or increased public
funding for something which is really
good like all things considered
which leaves the question of the whole
mix that might come to succeed the
journalism as we know has to come out of
the private marketplace in some way in
and you know lord knows what that would
will be or or or could be okay and looks
like we have just one more question and
when do we take that and then we'll
close with the co there's okay then
let's stop because we got two more so
what let's take it a limit speaking to
the last question we have a beloved
colleague at Columbia named Ken Pruitt
who is a former head of the Census
Bureau and who I know I talked to a lot
about these issues he's come up with a
kind of master list of all the ways the
federal government funds some sort of
objective production of information for
the public and and the grand and it's a
really long list and the number attached
to it is a pretty big number much bigger
than we're talking about and when you
look down the list you will see there's
a lot of different structures than just
the familiar you go up for an
appropriation every year and the cranky
old committee chairman Suzanne's I don't
like the look you know this so without
going into detail that doesn't have to
be the structure for a public funding of
journalism there are many structures
that have been developed over the years
where they're sort of buffers and so on
the system you know I'm not a lawyer you
guys might disagree but the system by
which federal judges are appointed for
example is pretty good you know that
there aren't a lot of just out and out
hacks appointed to the federal judiciary
so there's there's ways that federal
funding can be consonant with a set of
professional values that in real time
create controversy and unpleasant facts
and I think we need to
have that conversation about what those
mechanisms could be with regard to
journalism okay and we got two more and
then that will be it so there was the UM
though the other questions yes do that a
little bit too quickly which is two
things one is your right and it's really
important to me as a journalism educator
to try to raise consciousness about this
the most dangerous thing in the world
and it's very common as journalists
thinking I have no biases so in the
class I teach one of the first things I
try to do is say you have biases another
beloved colleague from another
discipline torri higginson psychologist
comes into the class he just this great
exercise should have him do it at an
alumni thing we he puts one half of the
class with their eyes closed and shows a
set of words another half shows another
set of words then he shows a paragraph
he says what does this paragraph mean
totally different answers because
they've been primed but the only area
where I want to push back is a lot of
people who aren't journalists think the
publishers order journalists to play
things this way and that's usually not
the case in a way the truth is more
disturbing which is we do it unconscious
that we're doing it yes sorry my name is
Franz Josef i graduated from the
journalism school in 2009 and went
straight to the BBC right after that so
first of all Thank You Dean lemon and
president Bollinger putting your
signature on my certificate because but
it doesn't happen often that Germans get
hired by the BBC these day but what I
wanted to say is where i'm sitting now
in the office at the BBC here in
Washington I I work with a lot of people
who are paid by various sources I have
colleagues that are publicly funded from
the licence fee in the UK and you know
they present what happens in America
today to their British audience I have
colleagues with BBC persian and BBC
arabic who until now used to be paid by
the foreign secretary foreign ministry
and I myself I'm commercially funded and
I report what's going on in the world to
an American audience and thank God that
Americans like Dancing with the Stars
and in the office because
that's how that's how we make our money
but all of these things have struggled
on the same level right so budget cuts
in Britain have forced the world service
to shut down six language services
lately including English in the
Caribbean and on the commercial side we
had our world news America program
cancelled from the BBC America channel
because Top Gear reruns were added more
money to that to that cable channel so I
do sometimes wonder where the future
really is ok well as a question actually
for my children who are encouraged and
graduate school no reason I asked here
because my answer to them is asked their
president or asked the journalism beast
how they can passionate it to their
learning in college they say most likely
I won't get a job or get a job I don't
know what kind of work learning to help
me and all of them token I myself and a
lot of fun talk about life
what Colonel life in the future so once
we know we are we will be more
passionate array cherry are all day to
day life suppose the way we are living
in u.s. fail for the maze democracy my
open market capitalism right or fair
thus which we like a learn other country
to follow us then what kind of life we
will have what is economical system who
after the capitalism we don't know
that's why we are so struggle in ventura
syclogic to our day-to-day life thank
you ok thank you so let's let's use this
to close the discussion in any final
comments you want to make clarity one
start well I and you know the BBC model
is what iOS site and my good friend
Katty Kay you probably know works there
and I always feel so MBS I was like why
couldn't we just have you know what why
can't we create the BBC I mean they
spend I even now probably with the cuts
i think the data i saw was eighty
dollars for every British citizen on
public broadcast money versus you know a
dollar fifty for us something right kind
of and it seems to work pretty well I
mean in terms of being popular and say
you know I know there are debates in
England about the it's is it too is it
the government channel or is it the
anti-government channel and I do you
know it goes back and forth but it
doesn't seem quite as vicious as we as
we get here but I do think I guess I
guess we could only hope that there's
something in the middle because i'm not
sure that they're not sure the model of
that breath of broadcasting really
really makes a lot of sense anymore but
i think there's there's got to be
something in between and I guess if we
can learn lessons from what what the BBC
does I think that would be valuable my
hope was always by the way that I wanted
to say this earlier that when we talk
about you know
foundation money going into stuff I kept
thinking why in those years when CNN was
on top of the world why didn't Ted
Turner instead of wanting to give all
that money to the UN create a you know
the the CNN foundation and just fund
that in perpetuity and you know that
would be I think a wonderful thing to
see well Nick and I have talked about
how universities run medical centers and
so we've considered buying the new york
times and running in journalism school
Nick would become the yeah rightly know
but I will say we're about to I hope
about to where we have i've turned on
the switch for us to start at the
journalism school a year-round local
news site partly for training purposes
and partly to fill gaps because we
published a report saying universities
have to step up to the plate so we're
stepping up to the plate and it's going
to be called in memory of our founder
joseph pulitzer's paper that made the
profits that in dad the school on the
model you mentioned it's going to be
called the new york world so stay tuned
if we were here this time next year i
think it'll be up and running so then
we'll do the new york times right okay
we can do that Julius do want to close
up I want to come back to Nick and Paul
star and this being a constitutive or
constitutive whatever a moment we can
call it transformative it is it is a
funny thing you read this book and the
whole book revolves around this concept
no one can know I can pronounce but we
are I agree with Nick I think we are in
that period and i think the kind of work
that is being done in a number of
different places is it's very very
important to do it in an analytical
level-headed way that looks both
backwards and forwards
and that keeps an eye on the values that
have informed journalism in the past and
that should inform them in the in the
future I think those remain constant I'm
fundamentally an optimist because I
think i'm reading Ron chernow biography
of Alexander Hamilton now and you know
it said I hadn't realized how much of an
early journalist he was in New York in
King's College you know writing for the
different local papers at the time
there's just something I think deep in
us that wants to tell stories there's
something deep in us that wants to hear
stories and to have information and I
think on balance the new technologies
that are creating this period of
transformation disrupting so many
existing businesses but they're also
creating so many new opportunities for
people to tell stories to receive
stories for information to be exchanged
so it's a it's a great time to be
thinking about these I please we're
doing it at the FCC and we're working
with the journalism school and others
and exciting times and I appreciate the
chance to be here with it a Columbia
event joyous and claire especially we're
very very proud of you and every time
your name is mentioned or we see you and
so on we all think of our links to both
of you and and so thank you for being
here today Nick as always thank you for
participating in this so that's the end
of this panel
thank you very much Thank You president
Bollinger and Claire my former ABC
colleague she was always out in the
field i was always stuck in the office
as a suit and julius i just want you to
know i'm using my tablet instead of a
piece of paper what a great day yes so
my list of adjectives is growing excited
proud impressed intellectually
stimulated and informed you can add your
own things to the list I hope you've had
some fun I hope you've made some new
friends and some new connections and I
hope this day makes you even more
enthusiastic about being connected to
Colombia as you can see you and your
ideas are valued so let's thank our
hosts the columbia alumni association
once again we want you to know that they
represent you this is your organization
a global network connecting nearly
300,000 alumni through 80 regional clubs
and affinity groups and in DC we are
represented by the columbia university
club of washington DC